hi everyone and welcome to PI data
meetup 6 it's really nice to meet you
all to see you all here and I'm going to
talk a little about what I did with
clickstream data in my company this is a
the conclusions from a research product
project we did which goal was to
understand how we can leverage
clickstream data for our purposes of
understanding our users so where we and
I work at blue vine what do we do we do
loans for small businesses in the United
States and we are really awesome at it
and the reason we're awesome is because
we are fast and accurate and why because
the vast majority of our decisions are
automated using machine learning models
and built by my amazing team and so it's
really nice that everything is automated
and great but in every automation
there's always the gray area of things
the area where we can decide
automatically and on this part we give
we let the analyst decide and manually
so in order to increase this area of the
decisions which are not automated yet we
need to make our models better we need
to make our data better and why way one
way to do it is to take wider amount of
sources and more types of sources of the
data for example and today what we
usually do to decide whether to give a
business alone
we look at this Bank reports as a
statement at credit report the web
presence of the business all kinds of
things but something pretty
unconventional would be to look at the
clickstream of the business owner in our
website to see try to understand the
behavior of the user this is pretty
unconventional in our field and that's
why this is still an ongoing research
and it's not deploy to production but
still I think from my own research and
many people here can see what they can
how they can leverage clickstream data
for their purposes so our journey with
the this clickstream data will be a with
the five steps the first step would be
to explore the data and define the girl
with the goal what we want to do with it
and then we will see some examples of
what kind of cleaning and pre-processing
this data needs and then we will explore
how does the user session look like and
from that we can understand what kind of
features do we want to build to analyze
these data and then we will try to
engineer some features and see are they
are correlated with our targets with
what we want to predict and the last
stage will be to try and build the model
from these features to try to predict
something that makes is of interest of
us to us
and besides create a model I always like
to try to analyze the results of the
models and see what actually this model
have learned in this process so first
step we want to explore the data so the
data I had is data for Mixpanel anybody
here knows mix balance do you know what
it is Wow okay so if you are product
people you probably know Mixpanel very
well because this is a service the
tracks all the user is actions in your
website it doesn't actually take the
digital footprint of where the user
clicked and which player visited and
records everything and what's really
nice about it that for us it can track
the user actions even before the user is
registered to our a website just based
on the cookies or of the users on it's a
computer and the fact that this was a
tool that will develop for product
purposes this poses a bit of a challenge
for me because I want to analyze it for
other purposes which is the
understanding thing about the users for
risk purposes in a risk evaluation so we
would we would see it
this poses for me how does our data look
like
so actually mixed file it has a really
nice UI which the product people at our
company used to see the funnel and all
the stages and how much time every step
takes and everything but why I used is a
database where all the user actions are
stored and what you can see here this is
the data frame that of a sample of data
I took from this database and I have all
these different columns here at the
properties ID the distinct ID this is
two kinds of ideas that by which I try
to recognize the user and cross it with
the user in our system and we have the
time and the URL which means this is the
action that the user visited this URL
and this time and we also have all kinds
of events that product defined and and
all kinds of properties which I don't
look at it's not interesting for me
actually the only data I need from here
is the ID the URL and the time and now I
decided to focus my research on a very
simple thing which is to predict whether
we will approve or reject this business
from giving it a credit line alone from
us this is the first decision we do
about every business that come to us
later on we have more decisions we have
to do about the other but to simplify
things I decided to focus on this now
usually how this work in our company if
we a gather a lot of information about
the user as I said before bank and
credit reports and all kinds of things
about the users and by using that we
decide whether we approve or reject
either by a automatically rule based on
the machine learning model or a bi
analyst for the minority of decisions so
a in this case I decided to try to
predict our decision about the user
without looking at the regular data
sources we use only by reviewing the
clickstream data okay
so what I did is to take the target
which is whether the user was actually
approved or rejected for funding by our
analyst and my data my features was
the clickstream information and I tried
a few directions and I will take
questions in the end okay and I tried a
few directions in my research and these
are these are a few direction that
didn't come out well in the end but I
took some insights from it for example a
Markov chain analysis what does it mean
Markov chain analysis it means that you
look at the transitions the user did
between one URL to another and you try
to build a probabilistic model by
looking at users which were accrued look
at those users which are rejected and
mapping the probabilities of
transitioning for each from each URL to
another URL for this kind of users and
for the other kinds of users and then by
that you can build a a model that said
who is this user more likely to be
approved or rejected using these two
matrixes of probabilities of transitions
so we try that if you have nice results
but it wasn't perfect it was pretty
mediocre and the main issue with it was
is that it wasn't so interpretable it
was hard to say why the models decided
he did so I looked for something which I
would be able to understand more other
things I tried and mostly because I know
that everyone is now talking about using
deep learning for sequence
classification because we actually have
a sequence right at the time stamped
with the a URLs it's like a sequence in
the error of events that happen so you
can use an RS in the lsdm for example
which is the record oil network it's a
network good memory that which is really
good at analyzing sequences so maybe it
will detect something in these sequences
and see which users are likely to be
approved or rejected and but the problem
with the deep learning is that it
requires usually big data a lot of data
and
line and what's so nice about it we have
a really nice day businesses which are
clients and some of them even have
credit lines of up to two million
dollars but we don't have very big data
because of that we have a bit smaller
scale that's what's usually used for a
deep learning I don't know exactly but I
can say that's wood and I read some
papers about it and company that usually
do a use the sequence analysis using RNN
for clicked in beta their health there
it's like care usually ad companies that
has like millions of clicks per day and
we have like at least scale less than
that so I think that's what one of the
reasons this didn't work out that well
for us and and another reason I didn't
want to use it in the end was because
again it is very hard to interpret if
you want to understand why lsdm decided
as it did then it's really hard there
aren't really good tools that does that
and so the final strategy I chose and
that's I'm going to talk a bit more now
this is just in front is to engineer
feature myself use our business with
them what we know that can be
interesting about users and do these
features and manually using pandas like
we'll see and then train a machine
learning model based on these features
not just take the raw data of the
actions but create the features and use
their model on them
I did here I did a it's a critical
situation problem it's it's two class
approved or rejected in the end you get
a probability
you always get a probability yeah and so
you can think now what kind of features
can be interesting in this case I mean
we are looking for all right
everyone was speaking you have to speak
within microphone okay so what what are
you looking for actually saying that you
have one user that comes what do people
do at our website if you are a business
owner and you want to get a loan then
you get into our websites and what you
need to do is to fill in some wizard
with the details and then after a few
hours you get approved or rejected so
for example one user can come to our
website and read all the information
about and all the details and only in
the blog of bluevine or I don't know all
kinds of things and then go to the
wizard and another a user can just go to
the wizard but do the wizard very slowly
maybe it will take him a long time and
to fill in the financial details maybe
we'll go back and forth in the wizard
all of these things I think that might
be interesting for us maybe these are
pattern that can somehow be connected to
the nature of this user and to submit to
with the future financial behavior so
these are the kind of things I looked at
when I build my future and so as I said
we have to do some cleaning and
pre-processing for this data for all
this work and this was a bit of a large
data for me it was about 10 gigabytes so
for pandas it was a bit borderline but
they I used to feel a few tweaks but it
worked but maybe if it was a bit larger
scale I would use desk or something like
that for parallel computing and and I
had a few challenges in the cleaning
pre-processing I had to map the IDS to
the users in our system I
to look at the URLs now your urls are
usually not that clean as you would
think they some come contains user slag
or all kinds of marketing keywords and
all these stuff you have to clean
because you want to be able to recognize
different URLs repeating for different
users at different times so you have to
do all these cleaning so we will see an
example of that there are also many
duplicates so I wanted to clean them and
also I wanted to cut the data in the
right decision point because I get loads
of that are all the clicks for all the
users but I want to predict only the
decision about the users so if I will
use data from after the decision point
it will ruin my model because then I
will see things I'm not supposed to see
right it's like a data leakage so I had
to understand where exactly do I have to
cut in my process I'll take questions in
the end and the most important things
think is to a identify user session
because maybe user got into a website a
few times before it was approved or
rejected so I want to be able to
distinguish between different user
session and so let's see what I did
first thing as I said I wanted to clean
the URLs now if I look at the URLs are
you able to see this Thunder okay and so
these are the most common URLs you see
they look okay but if I look at the left
common URLs then you can see il I have
all kinds of slugs and all kinds of them
marketing keywords here so I want to
clean all that so what did I do
I use this really nice efficient panda
string commands and they have em they
have all kinds of string commands like
splits and then replace and all these
stuffs that you can see here and also
they have reg X and so I used rags to
clean for example here if the user slugs
and so it's really nice and a way to do
it very efficiently and only large
the fact and now you can see that the
less list a common URL they are all nice
and clean it was one of the steps I did
in the clinic and and another very
important thing I had to do is to
understand the time differences between
the actions the user did I want to get
to know the users so it's interesting
for me to see how long did it take him
to do every action right so for that as
I said I had to clean the URLs and clean
duplicated URLs and and then I wanted to
just calculate the diff between the
timestamps right so then most native way
to do that would be grouped by user and
then this like you see here well this is
nice it works but if you want to do it
faster and I wanted to to make things a
bit faster so you can do it also without
group I you can just sort it all the
data by the user then sort it by the
time steps and then just do the diff and
then just remove the first row for each
users the one the one row which is not
correct because it's timestamp a
difference between the user and the
previous user so this is just a trick
and it's 10 times faster because they
saved us the group I so this is nice and
and then a after I have the time
differences between actions
besides that now I know how long did it
take the user to do each action now I
can understand how to distinguish
between different users sessions because
I want to understand what is the
behavior of the user what is the average
time the user does on a session like
does it taking a few hours or does it
take in a few minutes
so to be able to distinguish between
sessions I looked at the usual time dips
of the users I did this distribution for
the accumulative distribution plus of
the time differences and what you can
see here the times they are in minutes
that's most of the time differences in
my data or
up to a one-minute 90 percent or up to
one minute and then there is the long
tail for this distribution until around
30 minutes and also I know is that the
website just logs you out after 30
minutes so I thought that deciding that
if the time this is larger than 30
minutes then I defined that this is a
new session for this user okay now I
know how to separate between sessions so
I can try to characterize all the
sessions for a user and what I can see
here it is just the exploration I did
that you can see AI mark the new session
every time this foot is more than 30
minutes between it's a new session and
then I count the sessions using compound
for each user and they can see that
until decision and most of the user had
a up to a four or five sessions until
the decision point until they were
approved or rejected so this is just
interesting to look at and this is also
one of the features I later used in my
model how many sessions did the user do
until the approval rejected now is the
step three I will go through this really
fast this is just an example of the user
in order to a get some a and I don't
know where motivation or an intuition
about a what kind of features would like
to build I looked at the actual user
session until approval to see what it
did in a website how does it look like
and I actually chose the user which was
the bit problematic it took a few days
to approve it it usually takes less so
this is usual which was manually
approved like all my data they manually
producers and it's also a bit more
problematic in the users which are
manually approved and you can do the
first session here and you can hear the
time and the URL and it just came in and
read about levin lat
kind of credit he didn't do much then on
the second session it was a day after he
went in and start doing the wizard and
you can see he did some back and forth
in the wizard and he didn't finish the
wizard even God get to the last page he
got stuck on the business for personal
detail I don't know why and then and
this was a few days after he did the
wizard again and this time he finished
in about thirty minutes and then after
an hour after he finish the wizard he
got into the website again and just is
went into one URL in the website so it's
interesting I guess you probably wanted
to check whether it's approved or
rejected or whatever and then we can see
another hour later again is looking at
the dashboard looking at the flex credit
page browsing through the pages but
still is not approved and again and
again and and in the end he would prove
the two days after and so that's just to
give us a insight to how this really
looks in real life and now let's look at
the feature engineering what some
example of the features I did so first
type of session in the major major part
of the features that engineered are a
features that are around this session
trying to understand the characteristics
of the session per user for example the
duration of each session is interesting
the number of pages user visited in each
session the total number of sessions the
user had until the decision about him
and also is specific it were at the time
he did the wizard and how long did it
take him to do the different parts of
the wizard and whether finish the wizard
and how many times did the wizard all
these things are interesting actually
the first tool I did
Simo minimal median and mean these were
the all the features so for example this
is the median session duration and I'm
just showing how you can do it really
nicely with pandas so you can see that
they just did group by the user I also
grew by the session number and because I
want to group I per session and then I
take the maximum time for the session
minus the minimum time this gives us the
session duration and now you can see for
each user for its session you can see
how long this this test session take
this is the session number and after I
have this I just have to decide what I
want to do I wanted to median or maximum
minimum minimum on this data so after I
have the session duration here and I
converted it to seconds and and then
again I grew by a the user and I apply
Midianite I do reset index and then they
grew by the user and apply median and
now for each user
I get the median session duration which
is a what you see here these are the
seconds for the median session duration
so that's nice but how do I know this is
worth anything how do I know this is
actually connected to what I want to
predict so I can just throw it to a
model but I wanted to to review the data
a bit do some exploration so AI did two
things one I did box plot and so I did
the statistical test and and this is for
example a what I got and this is the box
plot and what you can see here is this
is the box plot a of the time the median
session duration of the approved users
and for the rejected user hi and I also
ran a F test ANOVA which detect whether
two distributions are different from
each other or the degree of linear
dependency between the future and the
target these are two same things and
what you can see here that there is a
significant difference between the
proved and the rejected users so
actually is the median session duration
for rejected users is usually a larger
so that's interesting I try to
understand why maybe takes them longer
to fill the details they have to bring
more gap maybe there's fraud so we take
them time to commit for I don't know I
don't want to say and so they want summe
well I don't know so that's interesting
that's one a nice feature you can get
you can also look at the maximum or
minimum or or average yeah all our
clients are from the earth maybe they do
it from China I don't know but the
business has to be from the US okay now
another example or feature is certainly
looked at and got into the model also
also is in the number of pages visited
in the shortest session so again I also
tried the minimum the maximum the
average you here I show the minimum so
what do they do here again I took my
data frame I grew by the user and the
session number and this time I looked at
the URLs and in just a slight length on
all the URLs I have on the list of URLs
and from that I get number of pages the
user visited in each session so you can
see here for this user and each session
number how many pages did here visited
77 pages in one session they're not
unique in this feature and so that's
what you can see here and then you can
apply on this whatever one's minimum
maximum mediums so for example here I
applied minimum on this so I got the
shortest a sequence number for it for
each user that's what you can see here I
do a reset index and then I group again
by the user and then I take the minimum
of the number of pages in the session
and then I just get the shortest session
for each user and and you can see here
an interesting phenomena every
the reverse from what we saw before but
it's not something else if you think
about it it's something completely
different and you see that for rejected
user users the shortest session is
shorter than the approved users and so
what I thought that the rejected user
maybe they need them anymore so they do
more short sessions that they just come
into the website and check are we
approved are real proof and just check
where visit just one page in many times
so this what I thought but again I can
tell so but it's interesting you can see
that it has correlation with the target
so it's interesting so this was the two
examples from the session features and
other features I used are for example
URLs just looking at the URLs because
you don't have to browse our old website
when you want to apply and so maybe it's
interesting
someone read all the terms of use or the
blog maybe said something about him so I
just just did boolean features for each
URL there the user visited and I also do
this did it in a nice efficient way with
pandas and I just grew by the user then
I do value counts for appearances of
each a a URL as you can see here grew by
then a URL is a value counts em on the
this is the number of time the user
visited each URL and then I use the the
nice say commanding I love a unstack
which is just taking the arrows and
putting them into columns and it's
really cool and then for each user you
get these boolean features of 1 and 0
it's actually supposed to be the number
of time the user visited each each
website if you use the value counts but
I did they I wanted them to be a boolean
just yes or no did you visited or not so
it just did larger than 0 here and so
this is a nice trick to do these kind of
thing that I use it in many many
scenarios
the value counts and unstack so you can
take it as a tip and other types of
features are developed and the number of
times the user visited the app and the
website two types of pages we have
and/or effect they up in the website and
also besides the URL user visited also
the sequences of URLs we did because
sometimes it means differently if you go
from one page to the others different
than you go from the first page to
another page it has meaning it can have
meaning they the way you do and where I
put also boolean features for this the
sequence as the user is it in our
website this was also and I got a
motivation to do it from the experiments
we did with Markov chains because Markov
chains is actually looking at the
transition between URLs so because I saw
that Markov chains were partly useful I
thought that this kind of feature can
help and give them more interesting
information and they build these
features also in a similar way to what I
did with the URLs viewers are visited so
I won't show it and and the last thing I
want to talk about before during the
model is data leakage and data leakage
is the thing that in every project I
always I always have in the back of my
mind and I think every data scientist
should always think about that I'm
trying to build a model that will help
us decide about the user whether its
financial behavior with the good or bad
but I want to give us extra information
I don't want to tell us what we already
know about the user I want to give us to
use only the information we know at the
time point of the decision because if I
would use other information then it
wouldn't help right if we just learn
something that I don't really have on
real life it won't work in production
and and then I thought and after they
loaded this feature maybe some of my
features are not priced maybe there are
somehow leaking target and
and one interesting thing that I saw
when I looked at this time to decision I
thought that it can maybe lick the
target because if you look at the
approved and the rejected user if you
look at the decisions which are
automated of course the decision time is
very sad because this is some model that
one just say yes or no but if you look
at the decisions which are not automated
the signs of decisions is somehow a
larger for approved users I don't know
what and but it's interesting and then I
thought if I have this interesting
correlation with the time to decision
maybe some of my features are correlated
with the time to decision if they are
correlated with the time the decision
and the time the decision is correlated
with the target then yes I'm the
decision of the analyst about yeah yeah
probably but so if if M my features are
correlated with the time to decision and
the time the decisions are correlate
correlated with the target then maybe my
features are somehow revealing the
target I need to eliminate the part of
the features that actually can tell me
the target I'll give an example and if
it takes a longer time to approve the
user and I have a feature which is the
number of sessions the user did until
approval then it's natively if you take
a longer time to be a prophet you may do
more sessions right just because you
have more time and so that I want to
eliminate from my model and so how I fix
that and what you can see here is that I
try to understand whether it is really
true I looked at the session number and
number of sessions the until approval
versus the time to approval and there
there's not very strong correlation but
there's a bit of correlation so I just I
wanted to feel okay with it is so how I
just got rid of it it's just not using
the number of sessions until approval or
rejection is just using the number of
sessions in the first 24 hours of this
user then I won't have
dependency in the time to approval and
then you can see that now in the number
of session in 24 hours and time to
approval it has no correlation so I mean
I fixed that and I did it also two other
types of features which were correlated
with time to decision like number of
visits in the website number of visits
the app all kinds of features which are
similar to this and okay so now we are
in the last part where we build the
model and look at their results and what
I did here the this was a research
project so I didn't do a very wide model
selection and I just took my go to model
which is of course a cubist
and I just throw all my features all the
features I selected which was good
enough to test the statistic test and
pushed it into a extra boost algorithm
to build me a model and what we see here
is the rocker in here this is the false
positive right and the true positive
right and the random guess in red and we
can see in blue the Train rocker and in
a Green Bay in test rocker and this is
actually pretty amazing result it's a
bit unreal and what as we see here this
is the it's also graph I like to look at
besides rock the probabilities plot as
we said this is a computation algorithm
what it gives us a probability so these
are the probabilities for the bad class
they rejected class and this is the
probability for their proof class and we
can see there's nice separation here and
these are really nice results much
better than anything I can find using
clickstream data online so I got a bit
suspicious and like always I looked at
the feature importance you can take this
from the activists a straight and and I
saw that the most important feature here
it's a very weird feature
then I put many features like the number
of to pay to the number of session of
two pages the user did and which pages
did he visit in these sessions so this
is session like this day number of time
the user did two page session and
visited the page of settings file a
login so this actually means when I
check what it means it means that user
that visited this page was asked
actually asked by our risk department to
give us more information so if it was
asked to give us more information
probably a situation wasn't that good
from the first place and so that's why
and the model decided this is an
important feature but in fact this is
not a very useful feature because it
tells us what we already know right it
doesn't give us extra gain on what we
know so I decided to move all the
features which are related to this and
that's why it's very important to my
opinion to look at the features a
decision from this model and to try to
understand the model decision before we
just throw it to production and and then
then I just removed all these related
features and then ran them all again now
that these results which are less nice
but they're actually more reasonable
they are more aligned with what you
would expect from clictune data which is
pretty magic right just looking at the
clicks of the person and understand
whether we should give them a loan it's
really crazy so a the Mau got a 60%
instead of 78 which is there which is
nice and there is still some separation
here which is really nice I think and if
we look at the features the important
features we can see that one of the most
important features are the time it took
the user to do the financial part of the
wizard which is interesting I think we
can also see that one of the important
features in the minimum number pages in
sequence the one we looked at if the
shortest sequence their length and we
can also see a
interesting feature which is the partial
wizard session duration which is
actually the time it takes the user to
do the widget the wizard when it was a
partial wizard when he didn't finish the
wizard so this is also interesting I
think and so and another thing I like to
do and beside the looking at the future
importance is also using all kinds of
tools to interpret my model for example
line I don't know if you heard about it
or not
it's really nice tool developed by a PhD
students from Washington University and
what it does it just gives explanations
pairs sample you can just give it the
model give it the sample and then it
will give you the reasons for why yeah
the model decided about a certain sample
and as it decided so what it gives you
is actually features features which are
most important for these specific
samples and how it does that it does
some kind of approximation of the model
around this specific sample because
mothers are complicated they're like
edibles they are very nonlinear
functions so it looks at specific sample
and does an approximation of the model's
function around this sample and with the
with the linear model and then it gives
us the the largest coefficients in this
model and a and the coefficients for
each feature in the in the linear
approximation so what we can see here
that's interesting I looked at the line
explanation for the users we looked at
before you remember the other we explore
together and we see in blue there are
the good features the one that says were
pulled us to direction that this user
was approved and in red these are there
we rejected feature the the features
that put us to the other other direction
now this user was actually proved but as
I said it was a bit problematic took
time to prove it and it got probability
of 56 in the model which is in the right
side so it's nice and we can see here
for example the fact that this user had
only one session in the first 24 hours
this is a good sign because this is blue
give to say a range of the of the value
for each features which was more most
influential so for this it's the range
that it's smaller or equal to 1 in this
case I put the XE so it means it was one
session in it first 24 hours this is by
the way of visualization I did it has
the other visualization I just want to
do something else you can see the ranges
of the values for the features other
interesting features you can see here
and is that the unique up count for
example the unique pages views are
visited in our app is smaller than 7
then this is somehow a good time again
I'm not sure why or if it's good but
it's interesting to look at and the
partial wizard session duration remember
this user did the wizard twice did it
once time it mean finished in one time
you did finish so this is like a bad
feature that it is take these two
cameras a long time longer than 800
seconds so this is a nice tool to try to
understand the model you're welcome to
check it out check it out it's open
source and that's it actually
and just summarize and so I think
clickstream data has a lot of
interesting inside freaking yet and it's
just from the air you don't need to play
anyone you just say you can get it
pretty easily and from what I found the
beginning of the project is the deep
learning is not always suitable for
every application especially in the
implication when we you want to be able
to interpret your your results in your
module decision and you can see this you
can do many cool things with pandas and
very efficient things even on a large
data set and you need to be it to be
always aware of the fact that data
leakage is out there are you coming to
get you
and you need to always try to understand
the your model and its precision using
different tools even looking at the
future importance can be very valuable
and that thing is M and well that's it
I said everything so thank you very much
I would then take you are we often yeah
if you have a question now hi Thomas
yeah the website I don't know exactly
now I did not Custer them like what no
but it's interesting to try yeah no I
just said I just created boolean
features and all that but I didn't have
that many URLs I guess that if I would
have many many URLs maybe I would try to
use something like worth of equity to
encode them in a more smart way is to
give it to the model but I use just the
sequencer now I just use short sequences
of talk three URLs at this point yeah um
he was not perfectly balanced but it was
okay was enough actually egg to boost is
the model I used it goes it works well
even with the classes which are in
balance like up to one to ten it's okay
still okay yeah understand is still okay
for my microphone but one to honey you
may want to balance your data changes
the way the education works and title
itself URL new URL like public
directions like the companies to make
sure that that's a great great point
we're actually just changed the whole
area desperation for a process in our
website so that's why this model is not
used right now in production and
probably we have to retrain it now I
don't think they changed that but they
change the registration process so yeah
that would ruin the model and you have
to build it but I guess if this will go
in production we will have to somehow
automate all the feature selection and
we retrain the model all the time yes
[Music]
well it's a good point right now this is
just the primal stage of this research
so I decided to focus on the first part
which is until decision if I want to
apply this model on repeat users I have
to build a better model using all the
data from after the decision I think and
so this was just the primal thing to do
but it's true now you can use further
yes so I talked about that I looked at
it I calculated time this of the user
actions and I look at the distribution
of the time differences and I saw that
the longtail and around 30 minutes and I
also knew that 30 minutes is the logout
time from our website so I decided that
after 30 minutes I define a new session
for the user
Oh
the the features the user the features
they generate I don't use directly the
the data is generated the features as I
showed you and this is what I put into
the model URLs these are visited the
medium session duration all these things
until the until the decision yeah yeah
but some of the things are also after
the 24 hours everything that which is
not depended on the time to approval
then it's also other but also after the
24 hours and I didn't use it as a
feature although it's interesting I use
it in other models a you you would think
it would be interesting but for now we
didn't find a strong correlation with
this feature one last question
yeah
that's true yeah but for now I just
decided to focus at this stage if I will
further this model they in or later then
I will probably use the final situation
of the user with whether it's good in
the end or bad in the end but let me
just try to focus it and see if I can
understand things that the analyst
understand on the user just from their
behavior or the users concept
well they're kind of competition to us
funbox but we do larger loans we do our
scale loans well that's it thank you
very much
[Applause]